gather round boys and girls and those
who are young at heart we've talked a
lot before about the wacky occasionally
wonderful but always weird creations of
the mysterious toy maker dr
wondertainment and today we're going to
do it again it's time to crack open the
scp foundation's toy chest and see what
we can find inside dr wondertainment's
inventions have been attracting the
attention of the foundation for quite
some time and with good reason whoever
or whatever the whimsical talented
doctor is there's no one else out there
producing quite as many anomalous
objects and marketing them to children
as playthings these aren't the toys
you'll find in your neighborhood store
or on someone's amazon wishlist there's
scp-445
the super paper that comes alive in the
form of whatever you fold it into
scp-1508 or mikey the chore buddy a
living cardboard robot designed to help
kids with their chores there are the
adorable yet destructive fire-breathing
dragon snails or scp-111 or scp-958
general beep who teaches kids about
military history and combat and helps
them build real working toy weapons i
could keep talking through the
proverbial toy factory but we'd be here
all day maybe dr wondertainment's most
anomalous trait is how productive he
manages to be i can barely send a single
email without three cups of coffee but
enough about me one of the most
well-known doctor wondertainment
creations is the little misters line a
series of humanoid playmates with a
variety of different traits we've
covered the little misters here on scp
explained before but let's do a quick
refresh just in case there's mr
chameleon mr headless mr laff mr
forgetful mr shapi mr soap mr hungary mr
brass mr hot mr life and mr death mr
fish mr moon mr red mr money mr lost mr
lye mr madd mr scary and mr stripes each
of these little misters from the top hat
wearing fish to the man who can't
remember a thing they're each special in
their own way but wait a minute looking
at them all lined up like that i can't
help but feel like i'm missing something
it seems like a bit of a boys club right
and why let boys have all the fun well
it seems like dr wondertainment thought
the very same thing because he made a
little mister just for girls enter miss
sweetie the sweetest pinkest gal around
at first glance you might mistake miss
sweetie for an ordinary woman aside from
her naturally pink hair and eyes no wig
or contact lenses here but like the rest
of her fellow misters miss sweetie has
more to her than meets the eye so what
lies beneath that candy-coated sugary
exterior to crack open that hard candy
shell and get the truth inside we'll
have to look a few years back to when
miss sweetie first caught the attention
of the foundation it all started in a
small unassuming town tucked away in a
valley flanked on either side by
mountains and thick forests it was a
peaceful place if a bit boring the worst
thing anyone could remember happening in
years was a cheating scandal at the
yearly pie bake off then ten-year-old
nina went missing her family was
terrified they called the police right
away but the authorities insisted that
it looked like a classic case of a
little girl running away from home after
all she had taken her backpack her
favorite toys some sandwiches and
bottles of water from the fridge she
would come back home soon probably later
that day and everyone would be able to
laugh about this by tomorrow but
tomorrow came and nina still didn't
return home people began to whisper the
way folks in small towns always talk
behind each other's backs was there some
trouble at home nina had seemed like
such a happy girl so outgoing leading
her troop in girl scout cookie sales
every year and singing solos in the
school choir something must have been
wrong though otherwise where did she go
then others began to disappear tommy
bowers was last spotted walking home
from school he fell behind his friends
stopping to tie his shoe when they
noticed he was no longer with them and
went back he was gone then mikey paulson
vanished on a camping trip in the nearby
forest his father left him alone for a
second in broad daylight just to gather
some firewood for later that evening and
when he called out to his son for help
carrying it there was no reply one boy
was catching toads in the creek behind
his house when he disappeared another
was seemingly snatched while walking his
dog the dog unharmed ran back home on
her own dragging her leash behind her as
she went it had started with nina but
now no one could be certain if it would
stop the townspeople began to panic
wondering who would be next who was
taking their children and why
as it always does in small communities
in the grips of terror suspicion began
to grow neighbors turned on each other
pointing fingers at anyone who seemed
the least bit suspicious local police
were baffled by the sudden slew of
apparent kidnappings sure they had a few
potential suspects an elderly woman with
the local kids claiming that she was a
witch a school groundskeeper that just
had a generally weird vibe about him but
none of the leads ever went anywhere
there was no evidence found at any of
the scenes where there were footprints
there were only one set the child's
leading off into the woods until they
could no longer be tracked tensions were
mounting and no one could trust anyone
anymore in a town where people had
always left their doors unlocked people
were boarding up their windows pulling
their children out of school and keeping
them home at all hours of the day if
they didn't after all their child could
be the next one to vanish after a week
of nail-biting tension and looking for
threats around every corner the town was
treated to a shocking surprise nina came
home casually as you please her parents
saw her come skipping down the driveway
a little dirty and clearly exhausted but
cheerful they embraced her weeping and
she hugged them tight asking them to
please stop crying we didn't know where
you were her mother sobbed didn't know
if you were okay or i'm fine nina
insisted they let you go her father
asked what i just got hungry and i
missed you so i came back nina explained
who took you her mother asked no one
took me i was visiting my friend nina
laughed her parents stared at her in
shock what friend her father stammered
the pink lady in the woods nina said
simply and then she rushed inside to
grab a snack and say hello to the family
cat police came by the house to speak
with nina and after talking in circle
about her friend in the woods and
refusing to say that she was kidnapped
she agreed to show the officers where
this lady in the woods was other than
her location all they could get out of
nina was that the lady was pink she
could do magic and she had lots of
friends they had no way to know for
certain but they hoped that this
mysterious woman would lead them to the
missing boys so that same day a team of
police officers none of whom had ever
seen more action than a parking ticket
or a teenage vandal spray painting a
wall set out to recover the kidnapped
children from the lady in the woods it
wasn't easy to navigate following the
directions of a child what exactly did
she mean by go past the rock shaped like
a butt or look out for those purple
flowers i like in spite of their
obstacles though they were able to get
their bearings they realized they were
getting close though close to what they
couldn't quite be sure when officer rita
flynn stepped on something that crunched
loudly beneath her boot what the she
lifted her shoe to find a piece of
bright blue hard candy broken beneath
the sole candy in the middle of the
woods as they searched the area around
them the rest of the officers found
pieces of the same candy in different
shapes and colors all strangely inviting
for candy that they found on the ground
they couldn't explain the significance
of the candy but they knew it meant they
were getting close they followed the
multicolored candy trail like hansel and
gretel tracking their path through the
forest with crumbs of bread they could
hear footsteps up ahead coming from a
nearby clearing through the trees the
team of officers could make out a log
cabin that looked like it had been
abandoned for quite some time as they
drew closer to the cabin and the sounds
of activity inside several of the
officers suddenly froze in their tracks
they insisted to be allowed to turn back
to go home they couldn't explain why but
they knew they needed to leave that
something did not want them there
officer flynn the only female officer in
the group scoffed at her colleagues she
urged them not to be cowards and to keep
moving there were children's lives at
stake
this was no time to get cold feet still
tentative but feeling thoroughly shamed
the rest of the officers followed rita
towards the cabin so far so good no sign
of the missing boys but no sign of foul
play yet either then behind her flynn
heard officer simon let out a groan of
pain she turned and saw him doubled over
clutching his stomach before anyone
could intervene his knees buckled and he
fell to the ground suddenly unconscious
flynn ran to check his pulse and it was
steady but he wouldn't wake up his
breath gave off a slightly sweet smell
and she remembered her great uncle and a
trip he'd taken to the hospital somehow
officer simon had fallen into a diabetic
coma right there in the woods before she
had time to think too hard about it
officer paul collapsed in the exact same
way right before her eyes all around her
as they attempted to approach the cabin
flynn's fellow officers were dropping
like flies she turned back to the cabin
and her eye caught the shock of pink
hair as a woman stepped out she made eye
contact with flynn who took note of her
unusual vivid pink eyes and she waved hi
there what's your name she called in a
syrupy sweet voice officer flynn drew
her weapon hands where i can see them
the pink-haired woman cocked her head in
confusion but complied no need to be so
mean she pouted it's just us girls but
that wasn't entirely true in the forest
behind the cabin officer flynn could see
humanoid figures trudging through the
trees but they weren't human they were
shiny hard and brightly colored she
thought of the candy she had stepped on
earlier and her jaw dropped as the candy
people approached her she began to
recognize their faces the missing boys
each and every one of them transformed
somehow into living hard candy holding
her weapon in one hand and keeping an
eye on the pink-haired woman and her
tiny candy army all the while she pulled
out her radio and called in the
strangest report she had ever made no
one in the town not even the chief of
police had ever heard of anything like
this but fortunately the police chief
knew someone who did an old friend who
devoted her time to investigating cases
that were impossible to explain less
than 24 hours after officer flynn made
her call the scp foundation was arriving
at the scene to collect the candy
children and the woman who would become
known as miss sweetie officer flynn's
report along with an in-depth study of
both the hard candy pieces and the hard
candy humanoids obtained from the crime
scene offered some insights into miss
sweetie's abilities her presence
inherently repels men that come within
50 yards of her and any man that enters
her radius will feel an immense desire
to leave and go back in the opposite
direction if he is forced to continue
his approach then he will begin to feel
ill experiencing nausea shortness of
breath and severe stomach pain finally
he would fall into what resembles a
spontaneous diabetic coma the only way
for him to regain consciousness is to be
brought back outside of the 50-yard
radius as for the hard candy foundation
researchers gave one piece to a female
d-class and another piece to a male
d-class to test the effect it might have
on different genders when the woman ate
her piece she simply chewed swallowed
and looked at the attending researcher
in confusion as if to say what was that
it when the man ate his peace however
his body began to undergo a rapid
transformation his blood sugar levels
skyrocketed rendering him immobile
almost immediately over the next 12
hours his flesh bones musculature and
all other parts of his body began to
crystallize into hard candy when the
transformation was complete the new
entity attempted to free miss sweetie
from her containment he was neutralized
using a flamethrower which melted the
sugar of his body down into a sticky
puddle any person identifying as a male
who eats a piece of this hard candy will
experience a similar effect just as the
missing boys did in some very rare cases
the transformed party will turn into a
candy unicorn rather than a humanoid
creature but the cause of these special
cases is unknown after miss sweetie was
brought into foundation custody and
given her official designation of
scp-2396
specialized containment procedures were
put in place to keep her in captivity
she was placed in provisional site 2396
and due to her distaste for men and boys
assigned a research staff that consisted
entirely of women any men or masculine
identifying individuals located within a
six kilometer radius of the site were to
be temporarily detained and questioned
about any possible contact with scp-2396
so every night in provisional site 2396
was ladies night but it wasn't much of a
party researchers were preoccupied with
finding a way to neutralize
scp-2396's anomalous effects most
notably in spite of her containment
small pieces of assorted hard candy or
scp-2396
would be spontaneously generated within
a six kilometer radius of miss sweetie
any of these that were spotted would be
incinerated on-site but the mobile task
force in charge of supervising the area
was having trouble keeping up male
civilians were slipping through the
cracks eating the candy and transforming
into candy humanoids or instances of
scp-2396-b
then storming the site and attempting to
free miss sweetie from captivity it was
becoming untenable to keep her contained
the generation of instances of
scp-2396-a was directly connected to her
regular consumption of sugar in all of
its forms which she requested as rations
the amount did not matter nor did the
form it took she merely required
something sweet once a day sometimes it
was a bowl of pure cane sugar sometimes
a cup of maple syrup on a staff member's
birthday they brought her a piece of
chocolate cake which she was especially
delighted by eventually they settled on
a single liter of glucose syrup once a
day hoping it could slow things down by
eliminating any whimsy or variation from
the feedings every time without fail
more instances of the anomalous candy
would manifest soon after scp-2396
ate her meal there was talk of starving
her to see if this could mitigate the
generation of candies but when denied
sugary foods miss sweetie would double
over in pain wailing about the agony she
felt the head researcher at the
provisional site was horrified by the
notion of torturing an anomaly that had
done no intentional harm to anyone and
insisted they find another way one
researcher dr o'hareli proposed a
solution why not try a sugar substitute
they decided to test it out giving
scp-2396 a liter of liquid sucralose
while behaving as though it was her
ordinary dose of sugar she accepted it
graciously and made no complaints of
pain at all after switching to the
sucralose the candy stopped appearing
miss sweetie was reclassified as euclid
and moved to site-19 after a week of the
sucralose-based containment procedures
dr o'hiri conducted her fifth interview
with scp-2396
for the sake of avoiding any potential
outbursts miss sweetie was led to
believe that she was still producing
candy as well as living candy creatures
a transcript of this interview is
included in
scp-2396's official file dr o'hearly sat
down at the table where miss sweetie was
already waiting with a pleasant smile on
her face good morning
scp-2396 dr o'haili began miss sweetie
scoffed and giggled at this opener oh
come on cindy you don't have to be all
stuffy with your best gal dr o'hare
responded with a polite smile neglecting
to correct
scp-2396 on the fact that cindy was not
in fact her real name alright scp-2396
are you aware another
scp-2396-b attempted to breach her
containment she referred here to one of
miss sweetie's candy soldiers miss
sweetie giggled that's just boys always
got to be making a big stink of things
when they want to get your attention
ain't it always like that never a man
always a boy always beating up their
friends when they think they're getting
too close a man's always got to have his
hands busy or else they're gonna be in
the air dr o'healy pressed the matter
they seem to be concentrating on taking
you away from here are you unhappy here
as cp 2396 ms sweetie's side a woman
ain't happy anywhere isn't that what
they say dr o'healy frowned i'm not
aware of any such saying miss sweetie
shrugged it should be one i don't know
lucy i just think it's because every gal
wants this big strong bug to sweep her
off her feet and these are sweet boys
deep down even if they're sticky i'm
sure they'd sweep you off your feet too
if you girls asked dr o'hare lee thought
about commenting on the inherent sexism
and heteronormativity of this statement
but thought better of it she also
considered pointing out that lucy was
not her name either but shook it off
then what about the instances that
resemble unicorns miss sweetie lit up at
the mention of these don't you just love
unicorns all little girls love unicorns
you can eat them too when you get bored
little girls get bored it's good to have
boys and unicorns you can eat when
you're finished isn't that a little
reductive dr o'healy replied miss
sweetie appeared to become irritated she
rolled her eyes look toots i'm a girl's
toy and it's a man's world what do you
want from me is that why you repel men
because you're a girl's toy miss sweetie
nodded dr w didn't like it when boys
break their sister's toys told me it was
damn near the worst thing in the world
and they can't break me they can't even
come near me well except if they're you
know all sweet and handsome and you're
happy with the way things are dr
o'hearly asked miss sweetie pause for a
moment to consider then answered dr w's
good in my book i always had a sweet
tooth and i always wanted to be a girl
kind of an okay trade-off if you ask me
you guys ain't so bad though even if the
food's crap don't know how you mess up
sugar sarah but you guys make it taste
like crap aside from complaining about
its taste and no longer being able to
produce any of her anomalous candy the
sucralose substitute had no adverse
effects on scp-2396
at this point in time no containment
measures beyond this dietary change and
making sure all staff that interact with
her identify as women have been
necessary so miss sweetie sits in her
cell in the low security wing of psych
19 missing her favorite sugary treats
but otherwise content with the way
things are and on the outside no more
unsuspecting boys are being transformed
into confectionary against their will
just to be safe though if you're ever
out walking and you see pieces of
delicious looking hard candy scattered
along the ground just remember what your
parents always said don't take candy
from strangers you just never know where
it came from now go check out
scp-001 a simple toy maker my favorite
episode and all the little misters
explained for more on the mysterious
creations of dr wondertainment